I can get core Marshal of this which is
pretty much like military jail you know
and in a foreign country could you be
dishonorably discharged for something
maybe
I don't know
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another super
sick episode of the careful boys today
we have Mr Walter Hong back in walty
walty
sounds very cute all right uh we've got
a really really fun careful boys off the
Record prompt
submitted by one of our loyal patrons
which one is it say their name it's
x-a-l-t so I think it's exalt exalt in
the highest
so I kind of like that all right so this
is the question what was the moment in
your life that you thought you would
never recover from career or reputation
wise Oh I thought this was a fun one
yeah never recover from sorry assault
Bart doesn't like it you go first and
said it's so fun for you
[Laughter]
okay what
that I would that moment in your life
that you thought would uh you would
never recover from career or
reputation-wise oh man I don't
my fear Gene is so high that I don't
think I've ever done anything where I'm
like oh this is gonna ruin my I take big
risks oh I don't really take huge risks
um it may seem like it like if I'm when
I'm staging people see me but like for
me they're none of those risky but even
doing stand-up comedy is so crazy though
yeah that in and of itself seems like
yeah you do that all the time but I mean
like I think when you have people see it
but for me when I'm on stage none of
it's risky it's just it's all like you
know I just kind of see it the whole
thing what do you consider is risky like
like with money or like with your life
or like things like that because like
that stand-up comedy is risky in in like
emotional risky because it's scary yeah
well okay so for me when I when I go on
stage like I don't get nervous or
anything like I don't have I don't have
that Gene but in terms of like let's say
like Financial like like someone goes
hey can you invest like x amount of
dollars in this it's like oh I don't
know like you know like giving you all
that like that that's something I would
be like I'd be reluctant but like on I
guess okay one thing I haven't done this
but like one thing on stage that I know
some Comics don't want to do is they
don't want to change their character
because if you change your character you
you take the chance of alienating your
fans that uh came up with you so a lot
of times Comics won't change even though
they think like oh I think this
character is the one that's gonna make
me take off a lot of them won't do it
because they're afraid that they're just
gonna lose or they're gonna lose their
audience so that I think would be
something that's like um you might not
recover from but I haven't done that
because like my fear genius not even
when you're like younger like the first
time you like bombed uh you know while
doing stand-up I've never bombed so
you're amazing
you know the first time I bought the the
first time I remember bombing the whole
crowd was British
there's only 15 20. so it doesn't count
they don't have humor but they're idiots
they lost the war bro
sorry I wasn't telling a bunch of dry
jokes yeah like no one laughed I I
rushed through my material it was
supposed to be a 10 minute or 15 minute
set I rushed during like five minutes
and I just got off stage was it was it
in the UK I know it was here I don't
know why were they all I don't know it
was just one of those shows it's a
British Cultural Center dude
but like yeah risk wise I mean I wish he
was at the London Club
he's on a fish and chip spot off I wish
I wish I could have done the if I wish
had I known the 555 yeah one five thing
I would have been able maybe they
thought they were at a spoken word show
and they're like this is a poetry yeah
not a trick contest it might have been
yeah that was probably like the world
contest
I think I've gotten myself into a bunch
of like
regretful or like doubtful situations
but I don't think I ever thought I
wouldn't be able to recover because I
feel like if I can breathe I can recover
it's just a matter of dealing with my
own like even like you know the story of
like when I was the Korean translator in
the military like that's a comparative
oh [__] oh [__] oh [__] oh [__] like I
can get Court martial for this [__]
which is pretty much like military jail
you know I'm like and in a foreign
[__] country could you be
dishonorably discharged for something
maybe
I don't know
[Laughter]
this old school Marines old school
Marine Corps meaning like my my boss
could just take me to the back and beat
the [__] out of me too and then come
back like handle it the old school way
so there's like that's tight so like
[__] like that like I'm like but he's
not gonna kill me yeah so I'll be able
to recover or if like if that's new
school throw me in jail I'm like I don't
know 10 years or some [__] maybe I'll
come out in 10 years 10 years like I
know my mind so pragmatic dude this
question is specifically did say a like
career or reputation wise you know I
mean versus like your life is in danger
you know yeah yeah so like you did you
feel like I feel like reputation I'm
like that's like a legendary and you
know that Chinese guy that pretend to be
Korean
career-wise
if you career things but that's what
[__] fairy tales are made up yeah
people we named this mountain after that
guy
I I've had plenty of moments of oh O's
and I think oh Oh's is like the best way
I can explain it because
there's been moments where like for
example I think my one of my biggest oos
is when I was like 13 and I was caught
painting on the wall graffiti right like
some kids were watching us they're
playing basketball
they they called the cops and all that
stuff so they're waiting for us as soon
as we got out there
it was like oh uh uh police and then I
was like I'm gonna run this way and uh
oh bike police uh
I was like oh man I'm not gonna I don't
know what's gonna happen now
because I was like oh [__] well I mean
like I don't know the process what am I
gonna do go to jail yeah dude that's
gonna be my scariest [__] dude like 13.
that is but here's the thing though like
when you're in a group I think that also
when you're not alone
and someone else is more scared than you
then you hide your fear and going like
it's gonna be all right dude yeah yeah
yeah and then there's this big ass
Samoan kid with us and he was younger
than us I think he was like 13 or
whatever but he was crying so hard and
he was such a big dude that we were just
like no it's cool it's it's okay you
were consoling him you don't know my mom
man hey that's true though his parents
probably came back she beat his ass in
the police station his mom's probably
seven feet yeah
yeah one of your friends oh they're not
gonna even though it's us and then like
really because you tagged I Joe like I
don't know we have pain all over our
hands bro like it was so bad and we're
at the station and like we're just like
[__] this is I don't know what's going
on and our buddy was 18 at the time he
just turned 18 it was his birthday yeah
and then the cops were laughing at him
like oh [__] you're an adult you get to
go in the big boy jail and he started
tears started rolling down his eyes like
they were smiling they were like cynical
like that cops have a funny sense of
humor looking back I'm like oh dude
these guys were just laughing at these
children and then they're just probably
like scare them straight type [__] I
don't know dude they're probably also
thinking like why am I doing this but
they have to do it right because they
someone called it they had to catch us
they're like I don't want to sit here
and catch kids [__] doing graffiti
like I want to catch bad guys right and
then so the whole time they're just like
roasting the [__] out of us and then
like our aliases and just
um but then for him like his eyes just
[__] the tears just rolled down his
eyes and all we see is him going into
the door and just the door slamming
behind and we're just looking at each
other like
[__] what's gonna happen to him that was
one of the last times I've seen this guy
and then like he never got out imagine
well we don't know what happened from
that point on and our our parents
wouldn't let us like talk to each other
and all that stuff and then I went to
like the interrogation room and then
they're just asking me all these
questions and I was like
[__] just lie just make up [__] you know
and then my parents come in and they
have to let me go but then that was like
one of my scariest like [__] what's
gonna happen now like do I go to jail
and then for several months it was just
like I can't smoke weed anymore because
they're gonna check my piss and then
like it was just these uh feelings of am
I gonna go to jail forever I just
painted on the wall how does that make
any sense you know yeah and then being
on probation you have to constantly go
to your probation officer and like be
like yeah I was at school and then I did
this and then they sometimes call
yourself this report yeah and then if
you got caught ditching that day you
like violated and you could go to jail
and [__] and I'm like I just painted a
wall dude you know dude remember
remember that just reminds me way less
hardcore but only because you guys were
there that it's actually funny and I've
maybe mentioned this on here before but
[__] Australia yeah when me and
Lawrence Cal got caught up at customs
and we they wouldn't let us out for over
like three hours or something like that
and so uh basically
um me and Lawrence one of my buddies we
had these tiger suits for this dumbass
show that we were doing on the Tic Tac
tour where I first met these guys what
are they skin tight no they were furry
they were like I'd be better if they
were skin tight they're very comfortable
with this whole LTE gray type set right
um but the thing is our boy Victor who
never [__] sent us like all of our
papers and stuff because he was a point
of contact with the dude what's his name
Ty yeah Ty yeah I think so Ty yeah um we
just didn't have any documents and stuff
when we were young and traveling at the
time so like we're like What do we say
at Customs I don't know so we [__]
we're so stupid but we made up a lie
we're like maybe this will make sense
why we have these tiger suits because
we're performing like what like our
friend's wedding or something yeah let's
just say we're like dancing our friend's
wedding versus like working in the
country so we had no [__] idea a lot
of people weren't doing this type of
stuff especially in our age and at our
group at the time so like if you didn't
learn you would learn the hard way and I
didn't know that Australia was going to
be one of the strictest countries when
it came to this those types of Customs
laws so then we [__] go off into
customs and they start asking us
questions obviously things are
conspicuous uh and they pull us over to
the back and they start checking our
stuff like can we look in your bags like
sure we start getting nervous they pull
out these tiger suits like what are you
doing with this we're like all right now
it's time to tell our practice and
rehearse live even though it's not
rehearsed at all it was made up on the
plane as we were landing and so we were
like oh yeah we're going to perform our
cousin's wedding I'm cool we're gonna do
random drug tests you know they just
like wipe [__] and they're like oh you
have traces of this
a parent [__] leave my boy Lawrence
has like six traces of everything on all
those things they're like you have
heroin on your camera I'm like how the
[__] it dude dude I have Jeffrey Epstein
habits okay I take pictures of all my
drugs it's crazy though because like
literally I didn't know the level of
[__] that like was possible because I
didn't I know every [__] drug that I
think my boy's done but I was like
you've never done heroin how's that even
possible but the fact that they like
legitimately found traces or whatever
right so they keep on probing us and
being like yo like what are you guys
doing we tried to stick to our line
because we just thought if we just stick
through this maybe it'll work and then
it goes so far that they're like we got
to take you to the hospital we got to
get you guys uh X-rays and I'm sitting
there I'm trying to [__] commissions
I was like look I will I will dookie in
a bowl right here to show you I have no
drug stuff on my ass like please just
like believe us right and you get so
serious they're calling other cops that
finally me and him break this is after
two hours wow
we gotta tell you something man we're
not here to perform when we're honestly
just scared we're here to perform for
this tour and we just didn't have the
documents our friend has it we just
haven't got scared he got more pissed at
us because we lost
but he also knew that like that was the
truth that was so they took us back and
then right when they were about to
deport us literally going to deport us
back to America is when the promoter
called like where are you guys and I'm
like oh my God please talk to God and
then that's 30 minutes later we got
saved because they had the papers
because they had the papers we just
weren't given it wasn't given to us or
whatever you know what I mean and they
were about to deport you guys literally
imagine if you guys got deported we
wouldn't have been friends because
that's when we all became and my career
would have been over yeah for you that's
that that's that you really answer the
question well you know what you want to
hear some real [__] because that was
fake [__] I would say
um probably the last dig moment is when
uh some of our past JK members left oh
yeah that was real because you know a
lot of things that we share in our Vlogs
JK news and all that stuff most of it's
entertainment value right and we have
our actual Dynamic behind the camera
which is we really try to create like a
family-based environment we go on trips
together we're at each other's weddings
you know we're at each other's kids
events birthdays on all that and so we
really try to cultivate like this family
and so when the past JK members were
gonna leave we had something that was
said off camera in a very amicable way
and this would be great for all of our
careers as we move on and then a video
comes out that was completely out of
left field that was not what was agreed
upon
stating like only one side right and
then obviously during that super like
woke era everyone wants to Stick it to
the Man so in this ecosystem people
think me and Joe or JK news is the man
so everyone jumps on that on on that
narrative and for me and Joe like we're
big picture thinking so we're like okay
we can see how this is gonna play out
there's this person's truth then we have
our truth and then it's going to go into
the receipt phase then we're going to
share texts past emails you know all
that other stuff then we're gonna have
to get other other people involved and
we can see this giant drama unfolding
versus which distracts from our ultimate
goal which is just making funny videos
for people to enjoy and laugh
so for us I think the the big oh [__]
moment at least for myself because I
don't even think me and like Joe ever
really talked like really debriefed
about it was like
now we only have one truth that lives on
do we just weather the storm and wait
for this truth to die out on its own and
we continue to do our own thing or do we
ever reveal Our Truth until this day
we've never really revealed our side
Dave is the homie where he has seen the
whole growth happen so David's like [__]
that I gotta share at least what I know
about the situation so that was really
cool for David to even come out but
during that moment it was one of those
things where I'm like dude the way that
the picture is framed is completely
inaccurate and skewed in One Direction
if people knew what happened outside and
were able to put even two and two
together from the Vlogs and you can see
the actual culture and dynamic that was
here and that was almost like damn like
everything we try to create could have
been spoiled like literally through like
one video yeah yeah that's crazy that
was something that we didn't know that
if we're gonna come back because it did
take a minute you know like a a lot of
like uh it was kind of cool because a
lot of the haters left anyway so the
people that loved us and saw and were
smart enough to see the real narrative
they stayed and thank you to you guys
and a lot of you guys like stuck around
and even joined our patreon stuff like
that but it's cool um that was probably
like one of the moments where I was like
oh [__] I felt that a lot of the stuff
wasn't even about us it was about them
taking out their anger on how they felt
about their own bosses
they're just you know unhappy with their
own lives because like a lot of that
stuff I think is just the time of covid
everyone was just getting angry because
it was like cancel stuff was happening
everywhere dude and I do think that also
that was also during a time when
YouTubers were getting exposed for a lot
of fraud [__] so people were just kind
of like dude I loved watching Everybody
not just JK but like everybody and I'm
finding out that all these people that I
loved and looked up to are not the
people that I thought they were I think
we got grouped up into all of that [__]
because it does come as a shock because
they do see the Vlogs and they do see
that everything was so like cool and it
was a family environment all these
things and then it's like all of a
sudden wait I've been lied to so
um a lot of that stuff I think people
wanted Clarity on but my perspective was
just like we never were drama so I'm not
gonna pursue that although a lot of
YouTubers like they get so many views
and so like they Skyrocket from drama
and people forget the drama but they
stay as an audience right and I know
that's a method that is used in social
media all the time but for me I rather
keep a tight-knit audience and still
stay as close to my real self as
possible and so there's more long
activity right because if you see all
these other channels that do thrive on
clickbait and drama and then the
clickbait in the worst kind like the
type of clickbait that gets that type of
audience to watch dude they're all on
antidepressants and they're all like
miserable and then for me I'm like I
don't want to cultivate that type of
environment I want to do this long term
and sustainable so I was looking at that
and I was like yeah we're gonna we're
gonna recover from this because I think
it's just like a snapshot of like
we probably needed a disrupter anyway
because during covid I think we we were
even as a group like certain people were
becoming too woke anyway so then like we
couldn't do our comedy and there was
tension within and then from I was like
At first I wanted everybody to just like
come on and have different points of
view but it got to the point where it
was no longer comedy it would and it was
such a weird dynamic of like people
wanting to shut down certain jokes and
things like that and I was like this is
not fun anymore yeah but then it got to
the point where now we can talk freely
and and have fun and I think that
preserving that and making that the
focus is much more important to me and I
think that will survive way past
anything
you know I remember when you guys were
talking about specifically that too and
and like bar said you know I mean like
playing it out and being like Harry
there's there's definitely one side of a
story out
um and if we were to like tell our side
of the story you can do this and this
and this so it's like let's just not go
down that path of German to me
personally just the way I I uh kind of
just live off of camera and so like I
totally respect that call did you guys
ever feel there was a moment where it's
like hey maybe we like owe it to our
fans to like explain something or
anything like that I'm not saying you do
I'm just genuinely asking I just think I
like I can see how things play out so as
much as I would because it sucks to feel
like you know the truth but you can't
share I just know that that triggers a
reaction and then it goes down this
endless route that distracts you from
like trying to figure out who's right or
wrong versus doing what you've been
wanting to do yeah yeah yeah yeah bigger
picture because that becomes the focus
of entertainment now because like now
it's about
um it's it's investigative drama right
and now it's no longer about comedy and
it's no longer about the conversations
that we have here because we're JK news
we're not like JK drama so we should
change it time for a Rebrand
people people always like to pretend
they know things it's like the World of
Sports like oh what are they thinking in
the locker room and then the analysts
will say oh they're doing this but they
don't know they're not in the locker
room it's the male version of the drama
stuff it totally is so people's like oh
I know what's going on JK news because
of this I saw this and that it's like no
you weren't even there like you don't
know and ultimately I don't find
satisfaction and like
hurt like in order for me to be right I
don't want to hurt someone's reputation
because all of these people that we
might have had disagreements with in the
past they're still sides of us that we
have good memories with where you don't
hate them and so like if you don't hate
people or like you don't want to destroy
them why say anything that might make
them look bad too because in order for
you to look right
people do look wrong and what ends up
happening is like now the perspective is
like okay now they look bad if they look
wrong so like people have to look at it
in a more macro perspective of like
action and reaction right like there are
things that you can say and if you do
come out and try to do it the most PC
perfectly like executed you know
explanation now it just seems like
corporate because that's what
corporations do is they go oh I'm sorry
for this action we uh whatever and
everyone's like that's a [__]
explanation I want to know your
perspective and your truth but that
could never go down because if you do
that then it opens up this can of worms
of okay now there's two sides and I
don't like creating this US versus them
I just like
the reality for me and this is how I see
a lot of situations and things that are
disagreements is you couldn't come to an
agreement because you have two different
stories
um and you both think that your story is
the right story so then there's conflict
there and the best way to move past that
is just agree to disagree and by telling
your story that means you have a
position now and you have a argument now
now you have to build the Army around
your argument and now you have to
compete on who's right or wrong you
literally just describe the history of
hip-hop
hip-hop culture dude where it was born
that was created but yeah I love Joe's
like dropping like gems of knowledge
while wearing a Kirkland sweatshirt
that's corporate and we don't want to be
corporate but I love Corporation that's
what makes it amazing yeah you're
telling me you don't [__] love
Kirkland dude I love kids you know I
love her and Ikea dude oh agree to
disagree
oh